hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast mitigating risks and
optimizing security of supply and
diagnostics i am jen woods of lab roots
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by saitiva for more
information about our sponsor please
visit their site at citiva.com
now let's get started
i would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the broadcast
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located in the far
left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
david raw supplier risk management
leader saitiva
for a complete biography on our
presenter please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
david you may now begin your
presentation
thanks jen and welcome everybody to this
presentation
uh mitigating risks and optimizing the
security of supply in diagnostics
i'll jump right in and take a look at
the the agenda the themes that we're
going to be exploring in this
presentation
so first of all we're going to take a
look at
the importance and impact of security of
supply
we like to take a data driven approach
at sativa i'm going to talk about that a
little bit
and then how we look at mitigating
supply risks particularly during
unprecedented events
and then what products and workflow
decisions customers can make to reduce
supply risks and then finally we'll wrap
up with a quick look at industry trends
so here is a synopsis of the
presentation if you like
how a day-to-day approach supports the
development and implement implementation
of measures to maintain supply levels
even in uncertain times
and as i said we'll be taking a look at
some of the workflow considerations that
can help customers
reduce
supply risk
so if we look at the diagnostics market
the sales of ibd products
used in point of care and clinical lab
testing
is for forecast to increase
close to four percent a year and then by
the end of 2021
be a a market that globally is north of
72 billion
together with an aging population and
those kind of trends with rising disease
levels
and heightened demand for detection and
diagnostic solutions
in response to the coronavirus pandemics
these things will all contribute to to
that growth and in in in addition to
that medical providers
uh are increasingly relying on relying
on point of care and clinical lab tests
for early detection to facilitate um
then delivering appropriate therapies
so
in in recent unprecedented events
we have faced uh inside teva in our
diagnostics business a number of
challenges
and those challenges sort of
paramount among those has been
production capacity
uncertainties around the supply of
critical raw materials
logistics routes
and pricing
and at the same time customer demand
increased tremendously for some of our
products and at the same time as that
forecast accuracy reduced
so as a result of this capacity
requirements were difficult to plan
and then on the next slide
we see
how we
describe what we view as an increasingly
complex supply chain environment
but the sativa security of supply has
long been an intrinsic part of our
culture and our business and our way of
thinking and we strive to take a
win-to-wing cross-functional approach
in an attempt to secure the
supply chain and involve stakeholders
from across our business
a number of ways we do this
first of all we
aim to standardize our work to make sure
that things are repeatable and
dependable in our processes and that we
have clear roles and responsibilities
and it when it comes to analyzing risk
we strive to take a data-driven approach
and this enables us
to look
more objectively
at how we prioritize
risk mitigations and supply risk
management
and in addition to that
material consistency is needed
because biological processes often have
narrow tolerance windows so in that
regard we're very dependent upon our
suppliers
so this slide uh depicts uh what we see
as a complex supply ecosystem related to
our ceramic uh production
and as you can see uh at the top we have
a number of raw materials
some of which are off the shelf simple
raw materials others are more complex
and can be
made to order by our suppliers
we have some of each of those that are
single sources and some that are
multiple where we have multiple
suppliers
so these uh this raw material um
ecosystem is uh complicated and depends
uh requires different types of material
management
to secure supply so the raw materials
are are taken in uh sub-assemblies are
or
semi-finished goods are produced
and then
the semi-finished goods are bottled and
packaged and then distributed to our
customers and
all the while this is going on we we
recognize that we need to
minimize the change control burden on
our customers we need reliable and
consistent supply
we need as
as low as feasible risk and a high
degree of transparency to our customers
and from our suppliers and
and consistent product
now one of the foundations
of our security supply supply program is
our supplier qualification process
and we have rigid
purchasing controls
measures in place
so the first stage on this slide over to
the left is our supplier evaluation
process
okay so the first thing we do and this
is a um
a process that's uh undertaken by
sourcing
is uh supplier selection
okay so that at that point we look at
the feasibility of a particular supplier
being able to produce the product
consistency into the capacity that we
need
before taking considerations any further
and at this point we might
select uh more than one supplier for for
evaluation
the next
part of the process is supply category
categorization and this is undertaken by
our supplier quality engineering team
and they
evaluate
suppliers based on the types of
components that they're going to produce
for us
and
produce a risk
delineation between the raw materials
and based on that
supply categorization then the type of
supply qualification
process uh is decided
and then in the in the uh the middle
section the wheel if you like
that's a um a graphic that shows how we
continuously monitor the performance and
re-evaluate
our supplier performance so it starts
with performance monitoring on occasion
in instances of poor performance we
issue a corrective action report
but we also continue to monitor
suppliers qms status
we have a
a rigid and very demanding change
control process in place and then of
course it's uh
it's fair to say that none of this would
really work without the collaboration
of our suppliers
so uh
just on the right hand side just want to
summarize that you know our suppliers
are required to have a quality
management system in place but we also
place requirements on our suppliers in
terms of what the standards they should
achieve in terms of integrity
business continuity management and
recovery
and supply capacity and capability
and we audit our suppliers on a risk
from a risk-based perspective
regularly
so in the next section i want to take a
look at how we use a data-driven
approach
to work with supplier risk management
so first of all
we have an in-house developed tool
called the sourcing risk finder tool
which takes a number of inputs both
internally and externally
and
contains over 14 000
component items
it produces a risk score for each of
those items and each of the suppliers
that
produces those for us
and then
obviously we
on that basis are able to better
prioritize our risk mitigation
activities
and here you see on the slide two or
three examples so we have for example as
a result of this work
uh implemented dual sourcing for some of
our key reagent components
we've increased raw material safety
stock from a
from a risk-based based understanding of
where that would be most beneficial
and for
for our more complex and high risk
components we
strive to use primary producers which
increases quality
and stability in our supply chain
so
in addition to the sourcing risk finder
tool
we also use a 24 7
continuous incident monitoring solution
that's provided by resilience 360. and
this provides
end-to-end visually visualization and
real-time alerts regarding potential
incidents that may
disrupt our supply chain
so
throughout
the kovic 1919 pandemic for example we
have received continuous updates about
threats to our both um suppliers ability
to manufacture but also
threats to our logistic partners in
shipping material to us um
this has been a continuous and an
ongoing uh
input from resilience 360.
so um
this tool also provides some
incident um advice when it comes to
natural and man-made events such as
earthquakes
strikes for example at airports or any
regulatory changes
now i'm going to say a couple more words
about the uh the sourcing risk finder
tool and give you some detail on that in
a couple of slides
um
so
this tool has been developed in-house
over the last five or six years
it analyzes
over 20 supply risk attributes
and i'll take you through what some of
those are in a little while
but we have
many many most of the components that we
source
are in this tool
and the reason is that we just think
that taking a data-driven approach to
understanding what
supply risks one of the highest supply
risks and how we should best mitigate
them
is
a worthy objective
so
the sourcing risk finder i said it takes
it uses more than 20 risk-based
attributes and here are some of them
so we look at
suppliers financial health we look at
various
attributes related to quality
the supplier is residing in a
geo geographical risk zone and this
could be a political risk but also
[Music]
more perhaps more obvious geographical
risks such as if a supply is located in
an earthquake zone for example
we do a business continuity management
survey on a subset of our high risk
suppliers in each of our factories and
that is also a factor
in the sourcing risk finder score and
that produces some supply chains of the
visibility as well
and then we look at uh
perhaps the usual candidates from an
item perspective on time delivery how
long it takes a supplier to produce and
supply to us
the transfer lead time is one of our
highest rated uh attributes in the
sourcing risk finder and the transfer
lead time is our estimate of how long it
would take to transfer to a new supplier
if we had to
we also look at
how much safety stock
we have
both
in-house and our suppliers whether an
item is single or sourced or has
multiple sources and for certain of our
chemical suppliers the criticality that
is to say what effect the raw material
has on the performance of the finished
goods and then
lastly we we take a view on whether we
have identified or implemented
second sources
and so when we've collected all that
data
we use this equation
to produce a sourcing risk index for
each part and after that
the sum of the the sum of the part
sourcing risk index provides us with a
sourcing risk index for each of the
suppliers
so we divided the sourcing risk index
calculation into two areas the impact
and the probability
and
on the left hand side you can see the
impact calculation that is transfer lead
time
minus the safety stock multiplied by the
revenue
so as an example
you could say that if you have a
transfer lead time that is it will take
you three months
as an example to transfer from one
supplier to another if you had to but a
safety stock of two months then
in the event that you have disruption in
your supply chain
you in theory will be standing still
unable to produce for one month and we
multiply that by uh the revenue that we
receive
associated with that raw material to
produce the calculation as to the impact
to our business
and everything else of the attributes
that i showed on the last slide is
included in our um the section on the
probability and
the attributes have different ratings
according to how important we think they
are
so that's how we calculate the sourcing
risk index
and on the next slide i'm going to
explain
business continuity management survey
that we undertake
uh as i said with a subsection of our
high risk suppliers okay so what we do
with this survey well first of all we
should i should say that we we take a
different approach depending on whether
the supplier is a
distributor excuse me or a manufacturer
and we interrogate our suppliers as to
how they manage their supply chains and
what approaches they take when it comes
to business continue continuity
management
so as i said we focus on
the high-risk suppliers we look at
whether the supplier has
calculated a recovery time for a major
incident whether it's done
business impact analysis or risk
analysis of uh of its key operations
whether a supplier has second sources
for its critical raw materials
the level of safety stock
and whether there are alternative
manufacturing sites
so in this way we hope to gain a an
understanding of our suppliers and to a
certain extent our sub suppliers
when it comes to how they manage risk
okay so when it comes to measures that
we take to mitigate mitigate supply
risks in our
genomics business just want to run
through a couple of scenarios and a
couple of examples
so when it comes to genomics and
diagnostic solutions
in 2019 we undertook a very thorough
supply risk analysis
which um
analyzed hundreds of raw materials and
we looked at over 5000 risk attributes
in total
and we looked at the finished
goods that we manufacture ranging from
ceramic
beads to dna amplification kits
so um
that project took
six to nine months
and what the result was we were able to
identify our highest risk raw materials
we developed a multi-year risk
mitigation program
and we have in place a cross-functional
team with clear action plans
and
we meet on a regular basis to ensure
that we are driving the rigor uh as
regards to the implementation of these
risk mitigation
actions
at the same time during our what in our
whitman business um we did a similar
exercise but this was based on
uh site workout so this took a much
much more focus on our manufacturing
operations so each step of our
manufacturing processes from the the
delivery of raw materials through to
uh all the resources and the equipment
that were used
were were analyzed and uh to gain a
thorough understanding of the level of
risk and the potential impact from
potential disruption
so
what the team did there thereafter was
create a comprehensive risk mitigation
plan
and this looked at the qualification of
additional raw materials suppliers
additional training and cross-training
of current staff recruitment of new
staff where needed
um
and then there was al we've also put in
place a security of supply leader who
leads these initiatives uh on an ongoing
basis
um
so this
provided us with uh you know a better
footing when it comes to
managing increases in demand in uh
during the recent pandemic
so on the next slide
i want to just quickly talk about our
risk mitigation toolkit so there are
nine
titles in our risk mitigation toolkit
that range from
uh implementing second sources
um
managing our inventory both internally
and externally in different areas of
financial and contractual support
but what i wanted to do on this slide
was just describe our approach to second
sources so we have five levels of second
sourcing
or dual sourcing
the first level is uh is market
screening and that's simply that we've
identified potential alternative
suppliers level two is a supplier
evaluation where sourcing look at the
supplier to see that they're feasible uh
in terms of meeting our standards and
our requirements level three is material
evaluation conducted by r d which is a
document analysis of the feasibility of
the materials that would be supplied by
a potential supplier in level 4 we've
done full r d testing
and
that bench scale to validate
the raw material
delivery and performance and in level
five we've fully implemented
the second source
and the reason we have different levels
is because our aim is to reduce the
transfer lead time that is reduce the
risk
and reduce the time it will take us to
implement the second source but at the
same time minimize the change control
burden as far as our customers are
concerned
so when it comes to
trying to position ourselves for success
in uncertain times
when the code of 19 pandemic started to
impact our business
some of the what some of the risk
mitigation plans were already underway
so we had already reviewed the article
data stored in our erp system to ensure
it was accurate we had the correct lead
times
and inventory values and so on and so
forth we started a program to look at
short-term risk mitigation initiatives
and this
was focused very much on
raising raw material inventory and
including vendor managed inventory
and we'd also started a project to
increase the number of multiple sources
and multiple manufacturing options with
the same source that we had for our high
risk raw materials
and in this in addition to that
we
continued with our open communication
and having a clear change notification
process with both suppliers and
customers
we continue uh with our
fairly uh rigorous auto
supply auditing program but we had a
review of the buying strategy
and we continue to be very rigorous when
it comes to the testing and very
verification of incoming incoming goods
so we have um
continue continue continue to conduct
regular risk reviews and these are
conducted primarily by the sourcing team
and um when we saw demand changing as a
result of the the kovic 19 pandemic
the regularity with which these were
conducted was
increased dramatically so we
try and get ahead of
problems and avoid supply issues
and then of course we continue to review
our strict quality and supply agreements
and review these on on a regular basis
okay
so um
in terms of where we stood when um
when the coronavirus pandemic started to
affect our business as far as magnetic
beads were concerned you know our
supplier risk management program was
underway but very very far from complete
because we'd only done the analysis in
2019
but we looked at
raw material both internally and
externally and that gave us a healthy
starting point where we'd already
taken some steps to to
increase that
we have close
relationships with some of our key
suppliers and they were really
instrumental in helping us
lower lead times and receive deliveries
of material
much quicker than would normally be the
case just to support
our very high and short-term
or urgent demand i should say
so
we're very grateful to have
great support from our suppliers and
extreme flexibility
but we've also taken uh at the back end
of 2019
we've executed on um implementing uh a
strategic review of our
strategic logistics partners
and so we would reduce the number of
logistics partners that we had
dramatically and this was implemented
actually january 2020 so we've been very
grateful
and pleased with the collaboration we've
had for our logistics partners and they
have enabled us not only to receive
material from far away suppliers but
also keep deliveries flowing to our
customers
so because of this we were able to
triple
our magnetic beam manufacturing output
in just a few months during 2020. when
it comes to membranes um
we looked at increasing working patterns
moving to 24.5 production with the
which increased production capability by
40
and we have the capability to expand
that further moving to 24 7.
i think i've already mentioned that we
recruited extra personnel
providing more flexibility in the
workforce and we moved to daily
prioritization meetings to make sure
that the in-demand products were being
manufactured on time and in the correct
quantities to support customer customer
demand
we now have weekly reviews of capacity
to ensure that demand
is not um
the capacity can meet the the demand
that is required
and in addition to that so the last
point is that we've implemented direct
shipments from a centralized warehouse
to reduce delivery times to our
customers
so
just finally on on on this point in
terms of the ongoing learnings from
these unprecedented events we found that
you know we were in fairly good shape
because
not all of our initiatives were complete
before the pandemic but we had put some
foundations in
in place
we need to further improve the quality
and integrity of the data in our erp
system to make sure that we are we can
rely on that and use the the system as
it was intended
and we are continuing a comprehensive
review of raw material inventory and we
need to finalize that strategy to
further protect the business in times of
crisis
we have ongoing work which we we will
continue when it comes to
developing multiple sources for the
highest risk items
and as i said at the start really
security of supply is a key strategic
pillar for the business
and we have a multiple multi-year
program of continuous improvement in
place so welcome and we hope to continue
to have this top of mind
continue to have it as a priority in the
business and the intent would be for us
to get
better and better
now when it comes to what customers can
do to secure a supply
there's a few points that i'd just like
to draw out really
so first and foremost we depend on our
customers forecast and this really helps
us plan
tactical and strategic capacity and
enables us to be in a better position to
meet your demand
secondly uh the issuing of purchase
orders firm purchase orders to support
demand
um and cover that demand is also a
crucial factor
when it comes to um
[Music]
the systems
and reagents choice we would very much
encourage
um consideration of the impact of closed
systems so for obvious reasons the user
the use of open systems does facilitate
security of supply because for
consumables uh consumable reagents uh a
customer can choose from a number of
vendors if they have to
if supply is constrained
and then when it comes to
designing components we strongly advise
customers to
take a a hard look at the security of
supply measures that those vendors are
taking
and it's also important to work with
supplier with suppliers that have strong
change change control notification
process is in place and
this needs to be replicated at n minus
one and then minus two levels of supply
to ensure
that uh
consistency of supply can be maintained
uh it's important to have a robust
supply audit process in place
as part of keeping our way of keeping
control over supply
and
it's important despite the fact that
there are change control
burden options
it's important to keep an open mind
about the possibilities of dual supply
options
[Music]
so when it comes to the future in terms
of security of supply we
see a few things at play first of all
the digital um
environment is going to be a key enabler
in this space
okay
so you know there are developments in
the pipeline um and they're really
potentially going to transform the way
supply chain logistics uh
supply chain transparency and supply
risk management management is handled
and we're looking into these with that
with a number of vendors um in
particular
looking at the use of digital documents
the use of
big data
machine learning or augmented
intelligence to support our decision
making when we have so many components
and so many attributes of play
and then of course
sophistication in the way that the large
data sets are handled is really needed
uh in the context of
interdependent supply chains
so there'll be a need from uh across the
industry through for increased
transparency
which will enable greater uh accuracy
and capacity planning
but also when it comes to uh
inventory holding and simply being able
to focus on uh prioritizing the
mitigation of the
most uh the highest risks
okay
so
uh in terms of uh
availability and quality of data um
you know that's going to be a key um a
key enabler so um manufacturers will be
able to
anticipate changes
they will be able to proactively adopt
adapt i should say operations to
meet rapidly changing requirements and
customers and customers customers will
be able to
track performance and
analyze
effects of different variables in
manufacturing
so
in addition to that we're going to just
spend a lot of time uh advancing our
ability to identify high and low risk
areas and i say using um sophisticated
sophisticated data
analysis methods to make sure that we
are prioritized uh in the right areas
focusing our risk mitigation
efforts
um on our highest priorities and
therefore hopefully continuing to be
able to supply our customers as they
would expect
so thank you very much for your
attention
thank you david for your informative
presentation we will now begin the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is
what investments are you making to
ensure business continuity
thanks jim um
so i think it's
it's quite timely really because
sativa recently made made an
announcement that
we are over the next five years going to
invest over 500 million dollars and
recruit approximately a thousand people
globally to support uh increased
capacity uh and this will enormously
help us secure supply in the future as
the
growth in the industry is predicted to
continue
okay our next question is
in what ways are your higher management
involved in enterprise risk management
well like i said in the in the
presentation we uh we consider that
enterprise risk management security of
supply is
is part of the cultural insightiva
we're very pleased about that we get a
great support from our executive
committee
they're very interested in the different
initiatives that we're taking to secure
supply to our customers across the
business
and on a quarterly basis we have
an enterprise risk management
team meeting with our executives where
we focus on
well the current focus areas in our
security and supply program
okay
our next question
can you give a recent example of your
business continuity strategy to enable
product deliveries to continue even
during unprecedented events
yeah sure so there was one
great example um
involving our target factory and our
genomics
genomics business where
um
the strategy that we'd set during 2019
as a result about our analysis and the
actions that we'd started to take
towards the back end of 2019 and early
in 2020 which were focused around
greater collaboration with some of our
key suppliers increase their raw
material inventory both
internally and account suppliers
and
increased number of multiple sources in
that part of our product portfolio
really enabled us to significantly
increase production in just a few short
months there was a lot of work involved
and we've got great support from our
suppliers and our logistics partners but
in the end it worked very well it was a
success story
okay great
and we have time for just a few more
questions i want to remind our audience
that those questions we were unable to
answer today or those that come in
during the on-demand period will be
answered by the speaker via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration
our next question what are your biggest
big business continuity risks and how
have you mitigated these
so um
in each of the um
the businesses are the factories we have
undertaken a business impact analysis so
for each of our major
uh manufacturing operations we
understand
uh exactly
what our largest risks are from a
business continuity management
perspective okay and those risks
do vary by sight
but one
one example in one of our factories that
it was uh
through this analysis we understood that
the biggest risk was fire so
what we did was we
moved certain parts of the of our highly
floured water supply
into an area that was
where it was much safer from
uh from a fire perspective but we also
have part of our manufacturing
operations uh operating in uh nitrogen
on
nitrogen controlled
fire suppressant technology so that's
one good example
great
okay we have time for one more question
can you describe your supplier audit
qualification program
yes i can so um
thank you for that uh question um so you
know that our supplier audit and a
qualification program um
takes uh
has sort of two key areas really first
of all there's the the
supply selection uh
stage
where we look at
what capabilities the supplier has and
make sure that they're
what they that they can do what we need
from a feasibility perspective
and then we would categorize the
suppliers by undertaking the risk
assessment
um
and uh there are four
uh categories to our to our suppliers
and depending on these
um
depends on on how often or under what
circumstances we all get our suppliers
so type one would be a critical supplier
which are offers significant
significant risk we have type two which
is uh we categorized as an important
supplier offers major risk
type three 3
an important supply with minor risk
and type 4 is a supply with negligible
risk and depending on how a supplier is
categorized we take a risk-based
approach to
whether and how we audit them so
we order our high-risk suppliers on our
on a rolling risk a rolling basis uh
but from a with a risk-based approach to
the
frequency and then some of our lower
risk
suppliers we conduct desk audits or
paper audits
so we take a risk-based approach
but we stay uh we stay in touch with um
most of our high risk and supplies of
critical or important raw materials
all right
thank you again david do you have any
final comments for our audience
no i just would like to thank
you for being my host today and uh also
thank you to everyone who
joined us for this uh for this
discussion and i hope in some way it was
at least a little bit useful so uh very
much appreciated your participation
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank david
raw for his time today and for his
important research
we would also like to thank labrutz and
our sponsor saitiba for underwriting
today's educational webcast you can view
the webinar on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now until next time
goodbye